today today it's really sad to say that
I've actually never voted before and I
never really felt that there was
unfortunately the stereotypical thing is
my vote doesn't really count when
technically yeah it really freakin does
especially in an election like this
where it makes me very upset
I'm top in my voting bag I need to have
some snacks in case the lines go along
I'm mostly upset because I feel like
this election has turned into just one
huge joke it is just one candidate
bullying the other the other bullying
the other one that's like the opposite
of what we want in this country is just
more hate-filled anything ever like I
just feel like it's all just completely
hateful people are more excited this
election to be over than they are about
having a possibility of a new president
and hopefully they'll bring changes to
this country that can actually help
those who need it
I'm sorry I can't bring you to vote I
love you I know
honey I'll just uh we'll just leave
those kisses for your own mouth the last
thing that I want is for my comments to
turn hate-filled you have a right to
vote for whoever you want and that is
the best part about this country so if
you strongly believe one candidate is
better than the other then unfortunately
that's your view and that's something
that has to be respected so please I
challenge you to be kind in the comments
on this day of need doesn't buy the
title you guys are probably wondering
who am I gonna vote for I think it's
pretty clear who I'm gonna vote for so
here's the thing if we're judging purely
on someone who actually has a background
in politics and knows what goes into
being a president who has been in the
White House herself long enough to
understand everything that goes into it
I think she is way more capable than
Trump who I don't even think would bring
himself to live in the White House I'm
sure it wouldn't be good enough or up to
his standards maybe I'm wrong but
I would love to see if Trump is
president how often and how much time he
actually spends in the White House
oh goodness all right well I guess I
should probably go vote now I'm stressed
out I feel I feel physically ill right
now Oh fun
better your cage good boy
mommy's got a gold vault okay I'll be
right back honey
you stay here be a good boy like I'm
feeling physically ill because I I just
Oh God
yeah I'm scared I'm scared for me I'm
scared for you I'm scared for all of us
Canada I hope that you will welcome me
with open arms I've never really been
there but I hear great things everyone
I've ever met from Canada is really nice
Oh God can't forget my dongle I just
don't think that the line is gonna be
really long so the good news is I will
listen to valuable goodness I have to go
to Starbucks so that I can ease my
nerves one of the things that I'm even
more concerned about is the outcome of
no matter who wins the divide in this
country is going to be so great and I
don't want people to be mad or upset
everyone so angry I wish people could
just be happy
Oh God ah Heidi a coffee and a breakfast
sandwich and a new president I'm about
to start my period so I think that that
means that Hillary is gonna win
I think Hillary's going to be president
because today my Appa says that today is
the day Hillary this one's for you girl
this one's for you and queen lower
tampon taxes because it's not a luxury
item it's a need Thanks
got the sandwich no sorry go boat oh god
I'm so anxious oh I feel sick
voting should be an exciting thing it
should be an exciting time I was
studying up last night on all the other
propositions that there are to vote on
there so
more to vote more than just the
president and and all of these other
things a matter whose president is these
smaller propositions also means so much
to your community to your state so study
off these are my feet walking this is my
drink I'm drinking I just have like so
many things to say in so many thoughts
and it just also is even so sad the fact
that no Trump is so crazy with his
promise to make America great again is
something that is powering people to
vote for him because they are so
incredibly unhappy with how things are
in the world that we live in I can't be
someone else I can't be anyone else I
don't understand Jim he's a personality
not a president he's treating this whole
thing like a reality show like it's it's
sound reality like this is actually real
life and for someone who has spent their
entire life
creating fake fictitious worlds
this one what we want it's all we want
but if that's what you want to go for I
you know you're entitled to your own
opinion
okay I voted here's the thing that I
learned from voting for the first time
and thankfully last night Jen and I were
doing some research on things that you
are supposed to be voting for and the
different acts and things like that I
can guarantee that most of the people
voting don't even know what the heck
they're voting for which makes me
extremely concerned for the fact that
people are just checking boxes for
things that they don't even know so like
yeah your vote counts but like if you
don't know what you're actually voting
for I don't think you should even go off
one of the reasons why I wanted to vote
this year because you can't complain
about something if you didn't actually
have a voice in making the decision so I
felt it was only fair but if I want to
complain about who actually wins this
election I need to have at least tried
my best to do my part and say hey this
is what I want and I'm gonna hope for
the best hey you know you have a sticker
on your head do you know you got a
sticker on your head honey you hate me
don't you I did my voting deed again I
have said this so many times
matter who it is that you voted for be
kind to each other because that's really
the only hope that we have left even
though this election is over no matter
who is elected we still will have
another four years with that and so we
have to attempt to make the best of
whatever situation that were thrown into
so friends happy Election Day I'm going
to edit this video and I'm going to play
call of duty to forget everything I'll
see you guys later bye
[Music]